sur le président ahmad allam unique pour
une fois que je vote un amendement
socialiste ça mérite que je me lève
madame la ministre
non non je vais rester calme madame la
ministre
pardon de vous dire vous en êtes resté
au précédent quinquennat
vous aviez une majorité absolue et vous
utilisez d'ailleurs à plusieurs reprises
l'expression rendre compte est ce qu'on
vous demande s'ils n'ont pas de rendre
compte parce que ça veut dire qu'on
vienne me voir a posteriori c'est de
dire est-ce qu'on peut pas anticiper
est-ce qu'on peut pas travailler
ensemble vous cherchez des majorités si
vous voulez trouver des majorités il
faut associer les gens si vous n'êtes
ici que pour venir rendre compte et
trouver des électeurs ça va pas le faire
et donc ça ne marchera pas donc c'est
extrêmement simple franchement cet
amendement qui vous dira revenait dans
deux ans
si on vous disait rené en quinze jours
je dirais bon mais à ma connaissance on
n'a pas changé de constitution le
gouvernement est à la disposition du
parlement pal inverse madame la ministre
al'inverse
et à partir de là et à partir de là
sincèrement
revenir dans deux ans bon voilà que vous
preniez des textes en urgence je
comprends très bien mais dans deux ans
on pourrait peut-être faire un point
vous pouvez peut-être nous dire où on en
est faire un bilan et je vais vous dire
je vais même vous étonner beaucoup
l'ensemble du parlement
c'est pas forcément plus stupide que le
gouvernement
le président mouillé
[Musique]